نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد
سلسله من المقابلات التلفزيونيه مع كل من
قناه اي تي في البريطانيه ومع برنامج 60
دقيقه الامريكي اتهم الامير هاري افراد
عائلته بالتعاون مع الشيطان
ويقصد به الصحافه الصفراء لتحسين صورتهم
على حساب سمعته هو وزوجته
البريطانيه انه فرما بريطانيا مع اسرته
الى كاليفورنيا في عام 2020 خوفا على
حياته وحياته اسرته واضاف في مقابلاته
قائلانه انه وضع حدا فاصلا عندما اصبح
تحسين صوره العائله على حسابه شخصيا
وحسابي افراد عائلتك وياتي اللقاء ان
تلفزيونيه
الذي يكشف التنافر الاسري داخل العائله
الملكه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع ونحاول فهمه في الواقع
مع ضيوفنا من لندن دكتور فؤاد عبد الرازق
البحث في شؤون البريطانيه والدوليه اهلا
بيكوا ميلاندانا صحفي محمد شبارو اهلا بكم
الكريمين استاذ محمد شبارو ما الذي يريده
هاري من كل هذه التسريبات يبدو السؤال
بسيط ولكن
البعض لا يفهم لماذا يحاول ان يفشي كل هذه
الاسرار هل التقرب من عائلتك وهل بهذه
الطريقه سينجح
اكيد لا هل الاسترزاق فحضرتك كيف ترى
الموضوع
الاسترزاق وتامين الت
مويزنيات اللازمه لحياه كريمه له
ولنجمه هوليود في كاليفورنيا الامريكيه
هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه هناك
مساله اساسيه لطالما اكررها وان هري لم
يعني يشفى من همم موت والدته ويبدو ان هذه
القضيه يعني تلعب همم على اعصابه ونفسيته
دورا ااه سلبيا كبيرا على مدى سنوات لم
يتمكن من تجاوزها بالاضافه الى طبعا
التنافسيه الغرائزيه بينه وبين همم ولي
العهد الامير ويلز همم اخوه ويليام همم
فكل هذه عوامل وكلها تلعب دور اليوم هو
يطلب المحاسبه او ان يكشف عن المسؤولين عن
قتل بشكل غير مباشر لم يحدث اذكرها ولكن
يكشف عن المسؤولين عن قتل والدته يكشف عن
المسؤولين عن الترويج او التمرير والتسريب
للصحافه من داخل القصر والمؤسسات الحكم
وحتى من بعض افراد المؤسسه الحاكمه كل هذه
امور طبعا لن ا من ناحيه يرى همم هاري
اجابه قريبه عليها مثله مثل غيره من من
يعني فتح صدره هو يتصرف كما تصرف والده
عندما كشف في لقاء صحفي مساله غراميته
ايضا والدته قامت باللجوء الى الصحافه ثم
يلومون الصحافه هو هرب الى الولايات
المتحده من اجل الخصوصيه واليوم هذه
الخصوصيه كشف ورماها كلها وفتح قلبه وبيته
وكل المعلومات التي بحوزتها
الى بيت همم
زوجه الاب في الوقت تحدث عن الكل وتحدث
كذلك عن المصالحه ساعود لك سيد شباره
يعني مسامحه مع الوقت او حضر يعني همم حفل
تتويج والده الملك تشارلز في مايو المقبل
دكتور فؤاد كيف ترى هل ستتم دعوته في مايو
همم هل سيذهب هل ستعود العلاقات لانه في
مايو ستكون هناك مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز
همم هو هاري على الاقل يتحدث عن مصالحه
يفشي اسرار وبعد ذلك يتحدث عنه صالحه همم
هل تستوي الامور هكذا
مرحبا بحضرتك واضافك الكريم في الواقع ما
اشرت اليه من موضوع المصالحه هي باتت امرا
مستبعدا
بالنظر الى كل هذه
الكشوفات التي كشف عنها والاسرار التي
اصبح عنها وضرب السهام في كل اتجاه ربما
نوع من التطهير لنفسه ما يسمى بالكثير في
هذا الشان بحيث اخرج ما في بداخله همم
مساله الكسب المادي لا اعتقد انها تلعب
جزءا كبيرا في هذا الموضوع لانه اختاره ان
يخرج الى الصحافه وعندما بات محاولات كما
قال هو للمصالحه للفشل اراد ان يخرج الى
الاعلان ويعلن عن كل هذه الاسرار وفي
الواقع هي كلها قنابل ايه يعني دراستها
ودراسه الحاله التي هو
ظروف التي صرح فيها بهذه التصريحات خاصه
معاناته وخاصه بالنسبه لوالدته يعني ال-
ال- الراي لهذه المقابلات والمستهمه اليها
او الكتاب الذي سبب وقد يعني كشف الكثير
منه حمزه قبل الاوان يرى ان يعني
يتوازن موقفه بين التعاطف معه وبين الغضب
منه يعني هناك بعض تصريحات المتناقدات
بصراحه يعني لما تستمع له في اي نقطه مثلا
تعاطفت معه يعني تعبتك ما في موضوع والدته
في موضوع المعامله في موضوع
القيود الملكيه الشديده التي تحاط به خاصه
تولى عندما ذهب الى الجيش قال اول مره
اشعر باننا انسان عادي يعني اييي ليست
داخل مؤسسه تحرم عليه الكلام تحرم عليه
الشكوى بل تحرم عليه حتى ان يغلف الدمع في
المناسبات والمناسبه بمناسبه بالغه الحزن
وهي اا وفاه والده الاميره ديانا وهذا امر
سيصعب على اي انسان فما بالك بالظروف التي
احيطت بمقت عليها وانا اثار
حول الدوافع قتلها او همم الحادثه التي
تتبع لانه ذهب يعني قاده السياره الى هذا
همم
حتى صوره بقت صوره تاريخيه عندما كان يمشي
وراء انعشي والدته ولكن استاذ محمد همم
همم هو في الواقع نتعاطف معه ولكن من جهه
ان التعاطفنا معها في السابق ولكن من جهه
اخرى هو يتحدث عن عائله لها رمزياتها في
بريطانيا وفي العالم ويتحدث عن عائله لها
تاريخها ما المتوقع من ردود فعل العائله
البريطانيه همم على كل هذه التسريبات هل
هناك صفقه قد تعقد بين الطرفين يقول البعض
بان العائله البريطانيه جدا عاقله وقادر
على احتواء الموضوع كيف
امور انفصال ديانا وشارز والده ووالدته
ايضا هناك مساله همم عمه الامير اندرو
وفضائحه مؤخرا يعني كل ذلك تم احتوائه
بشكل او باخر تحت عنوان لا شكوى ولا توضيح
ان كومبلين
هناك ايضا همم استاذتي العزيزه يعني نرى
ان الجمهور ايضا كان هاري احد اكثر افراد
العائله الملكيه الشعبيه في الداخل
البريطاني وخارج حدودها ايضا ولكن اليوم
هناك مساله استعاره رايت تبرز يعني
التدبدبا في هذه الشعبيه بين من يراه يعني
همم ضحيه ومن يراه همم مشاكسا ومجرما بحق
هذه العائله بهذه الاسره التي ولد فيها
يعني
لنلتفت للحظه لو سمحت يعني سته ساعات من
مسلسل من المسلسل الهمم يعني همم
اه ثم 400 صفحه في كتاب ولندري ما هي
الكتب الان اكثر من ثلاث او اربع مقابلات
ثم ستاليها ساعات طويله من ال ال ال
ستفرض لبحث ما جاء في هذا الكتاب وفي هذا
المسلسل ونحن نرى كل ذلك يعني عاده
المقابلات والمذكرات همم نادرا متصب في
مصلحه عضو من اعضاء الاسره المالكه كما
راينا مع عمه مع والدته معه حتى والده
يعني وبالتالي كل ذلك سيترك اثرا لا محاله
عن الموضوع
فؤاد
صيف او فتره تعبر وسيتم احتوائها كما تم
احتواء مشاكل اخرى في العصر الحديث
حتى يصارع الكثير منه لن يحدث
تتجه لن يدعى اليك شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
فؤاد عبد الرزاق البحث في شوء بريطانيا
والدوليه وشكر كذلك للصحه في محمد جباره
موعدنا غدا في نفس التوقيت السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]